this dais is the perfect metaphor for
where America stands today look at our
economy barely moving gasping for air
and desperately clinging to life very
much like Larry King the only
differences with Larry we have a
never-ending supply of guests never ends
this great country of ours was built on
its entrepreneurial spirit and that
spirit is best demonstrated by none
other than my friend Snoop Dogg his is a
tale of do rags to riches
true he's very proud of that that's why
I'm so happy to see snoop sitting up
here next to his former rival Biggie
Smalls right I want to talk about one of
the women of the day is this amazing
lady struggles with a seemingly
insurmountable physical handicap I speak
of course of Whitney Cummings Whitney's
career is crippled by her foul mouth to
hear that filthy language from someone
so marginally attractive is frankly very
unpleasant Lisa or as I call her Miss
USDA
I want you to be a judge at my next Miss
Universe pageant
[Applause]
you're perfect because like the universe
you're constantly expanding and filled
with dark matter
but there are some things that have
brought shame upon this great land of
ours besides Lisa I speak of the
atrocities that we as a nation must
endure like the Jersey Shore a piece of
advice my greasy friend you don't need
to put all of that product in your hair
you just don't look how great my hair
looks and I don't use anything and it
looks very good what's the difference
between a wet raccoon and Donald J
Trump's hair a wet raccoon doesn't have
7 billion dollars in the back
very funny very funny America is going
through tough times and we all need to
laugh true I know that better days are
ahead if we believe in ourselves
and the way I believe in myself and I
really do believe in myself then come
June if I decide to run you'll have the
great pleasure of voting for the man
that will easily go down as the greatest
president in the history of the United
States me Donald John Trump god bless
america
and good night
[Applause]